what is going on everybody welcome to
part 6 of our django web development
with python tutorial in this tutorial
what we're going to be talking about is
implementing the final step of our
personal website which is adding a blog
so the first thing we have to ask
ourselves when we go to add a blog is
you know is this going to be part of the
personal app or do we make a new app
well it makes most sense to me at least
that you know the blog is a
free-standing kind of app so we should
make a new app so that's what we're
going to do first so let's go ahead and
come to our terminal here and of course
we're going to do Python manage pie
start apps so managed up hi
just in case you think that's weird I
have like a little macro that types it
out so just because you're not seeing or
hearing the typing that's that's why
anyway packaged up I start app and the
app we're going to call this blog okay
so we've done that and we get a new
directory called blog so first things
first what's you know the first thing
you need to do every time you make a new
app that you at least intend to use
you've got to install the apps so we go
to my site settings PI and we
quote-unquote install the app this one
is just blog cool okay once you've
installed the app what's the other
pretty important thing to do well you
got to add some sort of pointer to it so
in the URLs PI we need to specify a URL
path that will lead someone to the blog
so I'm going to take this right here
this line just copy that paste and
instead of just to care it this would be
carrot blog and then slash and if that
occurs then we want to include blog dot
URLs now if we're going to include blog
dot URLs of course we need to make blog
URLs but the first thing we're actually
going to do is we're going to make a
model so this tutorial will be talking a
little bit about the idea of models
because up to this point we actually
have an action you talked about django
models and django models are pretty much
one of the most valuable things that
django is going to at least the django
paradigm is going to run off of and give
you
as far as a functionality so let's go
ahead and we're going to leave you or
this URL Zi and we're going to go into
blog so we're going to hop in back a
directory go into blog and edit this
models dot pi you should already have
this information here it's just by
default Django just automatically
populates this I'm going to get rid of
this comment though so in a model you've
got basically your whole models dot pi
would be this is your Django models you
can think of it like your entire
database and then within your models dot
pie you're going to have various classes
each class is you can think of like a
table in your database and then each
variable within that class you can think
of like a column from there you can
define various attributes to your data
so this would be like your metadata and
I think the best way for you to
understand that part is we just do it
and then I'll explain it once you see it
so let's go ahead and begin so this
would be our inner blah or or models dot
pi for our blog the first thing we're
going to do is like we're going to this
can be a blog so what does a blog need a
blog needs at least posts right in the
vlog so we're gonna say class post so
this will create a table table called
post and then models dot model models
done model so you might be thinking well
how does that create a table well if you
recall back in the beginning we looked
at our settings that PI file you don't
have to follow me here you can just kind
of watch in the video but if we go to my
site and then we go to settings dot PI
and we pull that up real quick we can
find looking for databases okay so in
here you define what database you want
the default is always SQLite because
that's a standard library with Python so
you already have it so so that's already
defined so what Django does is it knows
what your back end is it knows what your
model is up higher and it just generates
all the information required it creates
your tables and all this kind of stuff
and you'll see how it does that here
probably not in this tutorial but then
in the very next tutorial anyway going
back
Blagh others navigate there and back to
the model spy so this is a table
basically it inherits from the models
model now the next thing is we're going
to define the columns in our table so
what is the information we might need
with our our post well you're probably
have a title that'll be something you're
going to have the body information or
the post itself and you might have a
date assigned now for each column if
you're familiar with making databases
and tables and stuff like that you know
that every column and when you define
the column and you actually create a
table let's say if you're creating a
table yourself you have to you specify
the column name and then the data type
and then any constraints possibly within
that data type Django does the exact
same thing only Django has its own kind
of model fields and again it will
convert from the Django models to the
most applicable data type possible for
the database back-end that you chose so
I'm going to bring over this link here
this is just from the Django
documentation again all tutorials also
have text based tutorials I link to
those at Python programming nets in the
description click that you can find a
link to this exact page but this just
gives you all the possible data types
and constraints and stuff like that for
your columns I'm going to smooth this
over now so for title this G's will just
be some examples but for title this
one's just going to be a models dot car
field so it's a character field and then
for body we're going to have this will
be a models dot text field text field so
the idea with character field this is
like a shorter character field and then
a text field is usually going to be like
a you know a text field as it sounds and
then you've got for date this would be a
models date/time field and of course
like for date you can actually have it
be a car field if you wanted okay but if
you make it a date/time field you can do
all kinds of date/time of I don't know
logic and just use daytime as it's a
date stamp basically within Django so
it's important that you use the most
applicable one if you can so if you're
familiar with like a database backends
you could in theory call everything of
our car
right but that's not the best idea but
it's possible but not the best so then
as I said you know call a name datatype
and then any constraints you want so an
example of a constraint might be a max
length and then this would be 140 sorry
Pat on my keyboard there so so that's
like just one example again you can
always come to this models fields and
kind of read through that for everything
you need there okay so that's everything
we need to create a table but one thing
that you need now for like metadata
purposes is us for example if you want a
reference post like the idea of having
like this will create the table and
everything in our database it'll be
great but then like later on let's say
you want a reference like maybe you want
to list out all the posts okay or at
least like all the post titles when you
go to do that you're going to have a
little bit of a problem because if you
try to reference this any element that's
a you know the basically this post
object what's going to happen is I goes
here I try to reference like post title
that's like that's a post object right
it's just gonna literally be like post
object and maybe at the address where
it's stored you know on the hardware and
that's not a good thing all right you
want to be able to actually get the
string text of the title so we add a new
method here and that's just going to be
defined underscore underscore string
underscore underscore self and then it
just simply returns self dot title so
what this does is it will just return
the title so if we reference post title
that'll be a string rather than the you
know just calling it literally post
object at you know wherever and if
you're following along in Python - shame
on you but if you or you change this to
Unicode rather than string just a
fundamental difference between Python 2
& 3 okay so that is our our model now
the next thing we need to do is
basically define the URLs that PI some
sort of view for the user and then we're
ready to go live so I'm going to cover
the URLs in the view in the next
tutorial if you have questions comments
concerns up to this point feel free to
leave them below otherwise as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support and
rip shins in it so next time